you know a story comes out obviously you
you know the story nbc chicago and
you've been talking about this non-stop
for for a minute rod blagojevich files
lawsuits seeking right to run for office
again in illinois right former governor
of illinois filed a lawsuit in august of
2021 arguing his civil rights uh were
violated when the illinois state senate
banned him from running for state or
local office more than a decade earlier
in 2009 the illinois general assembly
removed blagojevich as governor borrowed
him from seeking elected office in
illinois ever again i think they even
put your name in there in federal civil
rights complained bogovic now 65
declared what happened to him was
unconstitutional because he was denied
the right to call witnesses and to
cross-examine the government's witness
uh the governor also claimed he was
denied the right to pres present
evidence especially certain undercover
tapes and as a result according to the
court rulings people have been denied
the right to vote who in the past
has had a similar situation like you who
went to jail did time came back and they
were able to
run again and they went back into office
in some sort of an office in the past
has anyone ever done that oh yes marion
barry the washington dc mayor
we have an alderman in chicago by the
name of walter burnett bank robber by
the way a great alderman been there for
27 years he's been allowed to run
i'm the only one that
expressly has been put in legislation
that says i can't run for anything and
there's a story behind that marion barry
what happened with mary he was caught
doing crackers crack cocaine on tape and
then he came back and was elected mayor
again
in nigeria maybe you should have been
doing crack rather than uh he may be
selling a senate seat hold on no no no
there was never a sale of the senate
seat i just got to say
july 22nd 2015 the appellate court
confirmed it they called it routine
political log rolling i was vindicated
on that um
okay so in 1916 by the way the socialist
candidate for president eugene debs got
something like 2 million votes in a
presidential race while sitting in the
state penitentiary in indiana so he was
actually able to run for president while
sitting in a prison cell in indiana
but
look there was a story behind that too
they came to me after i was arrested the
political leaders in illinois this is
how cynical they are and they were
offering me a deal if i step aside don't
pick a senator
and temporarily become incapacitated
there's a law that allows a governor who
if he or she is sick can be
incapacitated temporarily the lieutenant
governor assumes the responsibilities of
the office
they were going to extend that law to me
this is what the offer was if i agreed
to do this
then i could keep my pay as the governor
something like a hundred and seventy
hundred ninety thousand dollars a year
my security detail
and once i clear my name i can become
governor again this is what they offered
me
i turned it down for many reasons but
and part of the deal was you can't pick
a senator
i turned it down for many many reasons
chief among them was i did nothing wrong
i'm not giving it at all
and they know i did nothing wrong
because this is legal politics that's
routine happens all the time
so i picked a senator which pissed them
all off i picked roland burst an
african-american respected person in
illinois politics for former attorney
general in our state i did it in spite
of the fact that every democratic
senator including joe biden hillary
clinton all wrote me a letter saying if
you send us a senator we're not taking
one and so i send this african-american
man there and for the first day they
wouldn't let him in it was like in the
age of obama our first black president
we had gone back to the early 1960s and
james meredith is trying to get into ole
miss they wouldn't let this guy in the
most exclusive club in the world the
united states senate well america
watched this on television and within a
day
i think the african-american community
around the country saw it the democrats
folded and he be they let him in and
held a dinner for him that night typical
politicians right
so when i was doing that they said to me
if you pick a senator we're going to
throw you out of office before groundhog
day and we're going to pass a law that
disqualifies you from running for
anything that's how that happened and i
argue it's unconstitutional directed at
me and i should have a right to run but
better than that the people of illinois
should have a right to vote against me
if they want i'm not interested in
running for anything necessarily the
first primary i'd have to win is my wife
she's made it clear if i run i'm doing
it are you saying you're not interested
even if you win this lawsuit are you
trying to tell me with all your
political acumen and every thing that
has been built up with you over the last
decade you have no interest in running
for public office again
look
because i don't believe it there's like
i feel like i see
a a politician a well-polished
politician who has a
you know a a story where he's been
dragged through the mud and you have
something you have a chip on your
shoulder like pat said so even if you
win this lawsuit are you saying that you
don't want to run
okay i don't know if my wife's watching
this but let me answer this as best i
can okay because i'd have to get through
that because she's been clear if i ever
get in politics again i'm doing it with
my second wife and she's unbelievable
she did say that by the way she says it
repeatedly
what a wonderful wife she defied all the
odds nine to one odds when i was
arrested the vegas odds makers had it
that she would leave i know as a
statistical fact that a woman
and a man if a guy's in prison for four
years or more there's better than ninety
percent chance she's out she leaves she
can't wait especially if he's got a lot
more time to do which was the case with
me
she's defined all yeah she's a wonderful
mother best person i've ever known i
love her she's great
and she's gone through so much because
of the career i had she suffered greatly
so do i need to be a better husband and
think about her of course and that's the
first priority
in the event that i was somehow
successful in this lawsuit and i i say
somehow just because i've had nothing
but bad luck in that building but if
that happened are you asking me would
that wet my appetite would i be in
very interested in exploring the
possibility
i'm like one of those boxers who fights
into the 50s right you just can't get
out of that arena right
you want to get back in there and get
that title back so there is that element
i have and i do look at chicago i look
at our horseshit mayor she sucks our
city is
crazy with violence you're no fan of
lori life she's a bad mayor i actually
like the fact that she's uh i like the
fact that she's a woman like the fact
that she's black i like the fact that
she's a lesbian i think that qualifies
her she's a former us attorney
but she uh she's a terrible mayor and
she's given sounds like a woke dream
right there and she's and she's gone on
to this whole defund the police stuff
she's not backing the police we have
tremendous crime in our city and 75 of
the victims are black
kids black people and it's just tragic
anyway to answer your question if i won
that lawsuit i would of course be really
interested i might want to tippy toe and
tap my wife on the back on the shoulder
and say honey can we have a talk
and maybe see if perhaps maybe she might
have an open mind what would you run for
though if you could what would you run
for would you go center would you go
straight governor would you go may or
what would you run for
well i mean you know i wouldn't really i
don't see myself being governor again
i'll tell them here's chicago would be a
great job i'm not saying that i don't
want to make any noises or news because
it's
just
right now there's a law that says i
can't do it so it's but that'd be a job
that'd be really challenging what would
you do differently than than what she's
doing right now again with the whole shy
rack thing and you know every time you
turn on the news more murders in chicago
july 4th the new year chicago like it's
just constant what would you do
differently how could you change chicago
i'd hire 10 000
more police officers i'd get them up
from around the community a lot of them
from the black areas the black
neighborhoods
train them
the way you're supposed to be trained in
other words i double the police force
i'd have the backs of the police and we
know where the gang bangers are and we'd
go out and arrest them
we're not trying to defund the police in
chicago just the opposite i dramatically
increase funding for the police
you don't sound very much like a like a
woke democrat to me i'm an orphan
democrat that's why i call myself a
trumpet
yeah i think millions of others like me
across america are like this break down
what that what the you're the first
person i've ever heard use the phrase
trumpercrat obviously he you're the
first person to be fired by trump and
then pardoned by trump you're an
exclusive company right there what does
it mean to be a trumpocrat
a trumpocrat is
someone who's still on the side of
working people everyday people the
silent majority forgotten voices
who recognize there is a ruling class in
america their elitist snobs and they
screw ordinary people they lie to them
all the time like that canadian prime
minister trudeau what a liar he is we'll
go into that in a minute maybe but
um
and that trump has started a political
movement
that he's that's part of the realignment
of american politics where a lot of
traditional working-class men and women
who voted democrat historically have
recognized the democratic party has
taken them for granted and in many ways
sold them out like
trade agreements with china and some
other countries that have sent their
jobs overseas
those types of voters have always been
the ones that have been the ones i
really fought hard for they were like my
mother and father so i think uh i would
say that that's a trumpet and i think
you know he's got his own style
everybody has her own style but uh
the actual movement that he started i
think is for real and there's a
political realignment that's going on in
america and i predict that democrats are
going to see a tremendous loss of black
support in this next election and the
growth of the latino voters for
this new kind of politics that trump is
backing not the old-line republican
party of romney mccain or mcconnell but
the sort of new politics that trump has
created
i think you're going to see an increase
in latino voters eventually they're
going to become predominantly republican
voters i do believe that because they
work hard living the american dream
they're like the new italian-american
community in america and they're growing
the fastest growing community in all of
america so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you